Let's add a service worker
to the Wittr project and
start messing around
with these requests.
To make things easy the project
already contains a script file
at public > js > sw > index.js.
And it's currently empty.
So let's add a quick console log.
The build system picks this up and
the final result is served at
sw.js at the root of the server.
The extra code here is the output
of Babel which the script runs.
Babel let's you use some of
the newer JavaScript features but
I'm going to stick with ES5.
But if you feel like writing
newer JavaScript, go ahead.
As we talked about before,
the service worker receives events.
let's add a listener for one of these.
Fetch.
When the user navigates to a page
within your service worker scope,
it controls it.
The network requests for its HTML,
goes to the service worker, and
triggers a Fetch event.
But not only that,
you also get a Fetch event for
every request triggered by that page.
CSS, JavaScript, images,
you get a Fetch event for
each, even if the requests
were another origin.
And we can inspect them with JavaScript.
So in my Fetch event,
I'm going to log event.request.
To find out what kind of
information is in that object,
click through to the next lesson.
That was me trying to build
up some dramatic tension.
I mean event.request it's clearly going
to be information about the request.
Or is it.
Yes.
Yes it is.